I got some juicy info on Jeffrey Epstein
if is it legit juice well it's from a
guy who knows him who's in the science
world it's from a guy who was asked to
meet with him it's from a guy who's one
of the smarts people I know and does he
have any reason to chase this clout
right absolutely not he said it
privately in a very hot like he said it
privately among like like a group of
people that I have in the business and I
was like what and basically the theory
was that why was Jeffrey Epstein first
of all we don't really have a record of
how he started we we know he dropped out
of Cooper Union I know all I know is
he's a billionaire so Cooper Union he
dropped out of but there was didn't have
he was a math teacher at Dalton for a
while but we don't have like there's no
NBA there's no how did he become some of
this financier how did he become so
close to Wexler how did it become so
close to these huge names what why was
he living in that the most expensive
[ __ ] house in Manhattan with a heated
sidewalk why who gave him the money
where did he start with this we don't
know we just don't know go to his
picture for me he was a really handsome
dude too like a good-looking you like he
was look at him you guys look like
brother well this is how we're getting
this weird guy this is tricky
I know it's true exactly I know dude but
what's really weird about it is that we
don't know a lot about his origins right
however looked into it so this scientist
I know he was very interested in science
and he said he supported a lot of
scientific foundations and projects okay
why and one of the things that this
scientist said is he goes I was amazed
at how [ __ ] literate he was
mathematically in Scientology was a
physics and mathematics teacher at
Dalton School yes in Manhattan so
exactly so but dat grade dropped out of
Cooper Union so what the [ __ ] was it
about his visibility to really had a
command not a new stock right like
finance he knew a lot of this stuff
right so my friend goes my friend goes
to have a meeting with him in his house
see scan
Russ there but he's like those cameras
are there for me to see them were their
little girls there was a hot heiress who
was in her 20s nothing wrong on his lap
dude billionaire yes but on his lap
while he was talking the long story
short is my friend believes that this
guy was a construct what so well meaning
he is not who he was purporting to be
responding he was probably working for
someone like Israeli intelligence a
friend a mean soldier so why why so he
had his own Island
here his own plane why was he so
connected how do you get the most
powerful men how do you the most
powerful men money
he's a bladder how do you get them how
do you get the most powerful men in the
world to be your friend money nah
beautiful women young hot girls who are
willing to have sex with you right I'll
be your how about this though how about
this I'll be anybody why why do you
bring them on your plane why do you
bring them on your island well relax bro
and also it's a controlled environment
so maybe there are ability cameras
around so maybe now you've got dirt on
these [ __ ] sure yeah so maybe
now you're entering into and when you're
when you're knee to knee and in an orgy
with with with your boys that's pretty
bonding because you're all implicated
those they're the most bonding now
you're all implicated right don't you go
through that man okay it's like go on a
war brother it's a band of brothers knee
to knee my knee is on your knee we're
just going down that's told me in the I
wanna I wanna but that's right if your
DP and a girl there's nuts on top of
nuts
browning brother you got to be good
friends mouth though being a UFC fight
together right there you go a couple
tours I call it but we're all implicated
now now you got now how about this woman
who came out and said she had sex with a
foreign president with like a prime
minister do these things perform in the
world with the egos they're good they
like to fall they like to [ __ ] we ain't
[ __ ] we love the [ __ ] correct and these
dudes are I mean if you don't think the
most powerful men in the world are
banging the most beautiful women in the
world god there's a you know and I know
there's an underground oh and I got
something else to say I got something
else is he a spy that is the that is
like he needs to be a real rich
contributes to the
pains under whatever where you get his
money why was he so close to Wexler who
owned limited who owned you know I'm not
a conspiracy theory guy no I know that
he owned the limited he owned Victoria's
Secret he's the most he is the most
successful garment o in the world this
guy Wexler 80 something years old they
had a falling out about seven years ago
but why was this guy he was his most
trusted confidant
what a ransom train flex what was gay
makes it even crazier oh no
they run trains too so the theory is he
was working for an intelligence agency
the theory is he was a spy the theory is
he might have been working for maybe
Israel there's a lot of this [ __ ] going
around today maybe I'm speaking out of
turn but to hear it from the person that
I heard it from who's his smartest [ __ ]
and I hope he comes public and talks
about it cuz he probably will I think he
probably well on Rogen I mean I was like
I know this guy is real and he's serious
and I was like and he's not usually I'm
like this no this is real juicy this guy
really knows his [ __ ] and and and was
solicited by Epstein
so why for me I'm like a scientist he's
smart as [ __ ] they wanted information
who wants this information on science
why what are you looking for there's so
many of these let me ask you this
there's two sides to this yeah did
Hillary Clinton's people kill him a
trump go I think this is a guy who said
because we know you I think we all
agreed and commit suicide I don't know
how do you get into the prison I think
he might have offed himself because
because so much bro yeah but but I think
keep any other cell mate cuz you know
sell meat you know that yeah so maybe
he's a guy who said maybe he's a guy who
said I I'm gonna at the end of the day
there are too many secrets and I'm gonna
kill myself because there's a reason to
do it or you can bring the whole boat
down with you and get out or not get out
but at least get he's like a good prison
for the rest of his life you did add
some life well he would have gone your
lifestyle waived on it was he done
though yeah I cook turkey car way but
more important I need you like dude I've
watched Bill Clinton [ __ ] a
seven-year-old there's a chance this guy
was now it was definitely out definitely
India bro
Irv definitely in a definitely into
young girls and a perv but you know
that's so so he's he's a guy who was
having sex with I guess you know from
what I hear from 14 to 22 year old girls
okay there's that wanting to listen over
20 I'll have a problem now over 20 well
18 is legal so some you know ladies love
creepy even it's my age 18 like geez
dude it's technically legal when you get
lower than that
although this is 17 dude for yeah I just
think all these kids are [ __ ] at I
get turned up uh-huh
not the young one Las Vegas that the age
is 17 so you could legally have sex with
a woman at 17 it's when you get under
that and you're you're flying them
places it's creepy [ __ ] if their 20s
flying around welcome to the real world
the here's the thing here's the thing
these girls are having sex
III I'm curious to see will find out
that that Clinton and these guys were
having sex with these women on this
plane and their little idea normil the
island on the planes they have a bunch
of stuff I wonder who else is involved
that Island well who brought the island
the island was living in Wexler's house
they don't have a transaction of the
from what I understand they don't have
an ad they don't have a transaction of
of the house being bought why was he
living the most expensive house he
didn't buy it it's just always a
billionaire so but even though yeah five
hundred million dollars wasn't a
billionaire he was about worth about 500
milliwatts a lot of money Oh in the bay
yeah that's a lot but also the like the
guy who owns Virgin Records has a island
like you we abide an island you an
island pretty cheap yeah it is fine look
at his Mexican states have a primary age
of consent which may be as low as 12 so
in some countries mxk is legal it makes
you get it together no I think in Mexico
I mean I think that's a weird we have to
be careful with that statistic but at
the end of the day that's a lot of
countries fifteen sixteen you see it you
see it it's crazy the age of contraction
countries of Central America range from
14 to 18 there you go so how funny in in
South America he's not gonna be here
fine so you think you spy huh there was
a chance though and a lot of this stuff
that he could have in
some ways fought this for a long time or
he was a big flight risk they set bail
at crazy amounts I just think this is a
guy who might have been intelligence
operative who is in the business of
getting powerful men in the compromised
position saying a lot and saying
conspiracy now and said you know what
I'm a patriot I'm killing myself that's
one way to go about it I also think when
you're a billionaire and you're living
in these mansions in this place of
Manhattan they go from there dubbed
prison cell you're like oh [ __ ] oh no
it's done huh you want me to spend the
rest of my you're done I'm used to bust
a nut but I'll see ya that's locked up
in jail to use protection you're living
in you know confinement for the rest of
your life in you're a billionaire living
in the most exclusive homes your private
jet your [ __ ] chicks eating the best
food you got the dopest cakes
your right coolest friends and go from
that to being in a [ __ ] cell he's
like oh [ __ ] Eddie knows he's never
getting out Isaac I'm out dude
I'm really curious to see and why did he
why was he able to kill himself like
that here's why wasn't he monitored
what's really going on so strange so so
did he help why do you guys look exactly
the same
oh that's a different story maybe you
have help we'll get him later Brian's
older brother but did he have help from
a foreign agency who knows it's really
interesting man I'm actually curious now
and I think we're gonna find out more
yeah
suicide watch I don't know if we'll find
out more I don't think we will we may
not ever meet doesn't let us do that
stuff but did this woman Maxwell who's
now being indicted because she was his
Wrangler allegedly I think this is more
than just perversion I think I think
it's a whole ring if you hadn't said
triple in here he would unleash on this
but I think it's a whole ring of
higher-ups politicians what a [ __ ]
this dude all of them all all connected
they're busting nuts and little girls I
agree and it is shady [ __ ] well they're
busting nuts in in in like sex trade 18
19 20 year-olds two that you want to get
most powerful men have you say we have
these tens where 20 they're like they're
really hot and I'll have sex with you
[ __ ] dudes are like I don't give a
[ __ ] dude if you're president country if
if William Morris OCA if William Morris
went
a shop we got these two 20 year old
smoke shows come over here I'm going
over this what I'm doing the way Sam
Brennan we're not going over there
you send them over to us I don't know
what kind of cameras you have and I'm
just gonna talk to them and tell them
not to do this I would have to sit them
down and say young lady this is not this
is a dead end
yeah it's very strange man guards do not
check on Epstein for several hours even
though standard procedure requires a
physical check every 30 minutes it did
there's so much foul play here I'm not
I'm not that big conspiracy theorist
either but this is where eyes come on I
never would have thought this until I
had this conversation this weekend and
and I was at dinner Saturday when I
wanted you to come and that was one of
the reasons I wanted to come because you
would have been you would have been like
people at the dinner table were like
this they were like they literally were
like their minds and I had some
intelligent people at the table they
were like they were looking at him like
this
what the [ __ ] and even and me too and I
was like you know me with I always think
it's all [ __ ] conspiracy theories
foreign intelligence agencies are very
organized do you know what do they know
what the [ __ ] they're doing and this
doesn't add up this this makes no sense
it does make sense that a foreign
intelligence agency would want to get
compromised a bunch of wealthy powerful
men for information for favors or
whatever that makes a labral mmm yeah
yeah yeah yeah watch your tongue Oh
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[Laughter]